my wife is like insane about this stuff
she has a drawer full of coupons so we
went to Costco this weekend because we
had a $20 off or something like that
coupon so we still use coupons or
[Music]
coupons all right what's going on this
is Sam Sean's out with some surgery I've
been telling people he's getting a nose
job I don't know if that's true but
let's just pretend it is but anyway we
are doing a quick
10 or 15 minute Q&A session I asked some
of the listeners and some of my Twitter
fans what type of questions they had for
for me and we'll talk about it let's get
into it so all right what's the uh first
question what do we got let's start with
one that's really timely you're about to
be a dad someone's asking what is top of
Mind as you become a
dad so I'm gonna have a child November 1
that's the due date we'll see a little
girl what um so in preparation of having
this baby I was like freaking out about
like just the actual uh like the
physical her physical wellbeing of
raising her and so I read the biography
of Louis and Clark because I remember
that sacka joa had a kid like on that
Journey or something like that and so I
wanted to read the book and so it turns
out she had a three-month-old that she
carried like in a little sack across
America for two years and like you know
in the winter and um that kind of like
encouraged me like I'm not going to hurt
this baby so I'm not too worried about
that I would say the biggest thing
though that I am freaked out about is
raising a spoiled kid and raising a kid
that's going to be a drug addict um I'm
very like like that like I I genuinely
have like a deep fear in me and so I've
been trying to figure out how do I like
in a very healthy way withhold things
from her like how do I not give her what
she wants just in order to instill some
types of grit because the sounds kind of
douchy but I can give her anything she
wants like in terms of like physical
stuff and I'm really freaking out about
how do I stay strong and not give her
what she wants in order to create grit
and how do I make sure that she's not
spoiled and works hard but my biggest
fear is Raising like a kid
who is freaking out over that or or or
who like just feels like she doesn't
need to work and so my current thinking
this has not been settled but my
thinking this is just me not my family
me is the only thing that I'll pay for
is free tuition
and free medical for life and beyond
that give her nothing um that's kind of
like my current thinking um that's what
I had growing up my parents paid for my
school and I never had to worry about
getting braces or anything like that and
that's kind of like where I am now I
read the Titan by John Rockefeller and
he was the richest person in the world
and his wife has this famous quote where
she says something like the biggest joy
that I have in life right now is
withholding
from my children things that they want
because I know it's going to make them
stronger and I'm kind of in that camp at
the moment on how to do that but I um I
don't feel very confident on the right
way that I'm going to do that but my
fear is the outcome of a drug addicted
indulgent child who won't work hard that
that's my biggest fear at the moment and
so I'm
preparing by like getting my mind right
on how to like withhold things from her
and not give in because I do give in to
a lot of things is that a good answer
you have kids am I am I I'm I'm a very
withholding weather so I totally get and
speaking of you being effing Rich this
is a next question that I personally am
curious about it's what's the biggest
difference in your lifestyle now that
you're effing rich I have nothing to do
with picking these questions I just want
to say that I hate talking I don't like
that topic but I will discuss it so
basically before I sold my first company
I I my four years of salary leading up
to it was 20,000 a year 20,000 a year I
think I paid myself 150,000 a year and
then the last year I think I paid myself
$350,000 a year so for the first while I
didn't have a lot of money I was I was I
I didn't have much and then all of a
sudden I sold the business and I I had
enough uh at first I did something that
I advise everyone not to do which is I
bought a few things I bought some real
estate I think that I bought a fancy car
I think
that that brings close to no happiness
um and might be one of those things that
you have to go through in order to um to
truly appreciate but I think that if you
do have a windfall you likely shouldn't
buy anything crazy fancy for the first
year or two and just get used to it but
I've also learned there's this like um
story about a um this study about these
people who studied uh
amputees and they found that after 6
months the level of Happiness went back
to where they were when they had both
legs so you you get hurt you lose your
leg you're bummed for a little while
after six months you go right back to
feeling as good as you did with two legs
that kind of happens um when I think
when you make some money um but the
biggest thing that it did was not what
it could purchase you but the biggest
change is my confidence my confidence
went through the roof I'm incredibly
confident in my ability to start
something and to see it through to be a
success I don't think that I have the
confidence where I think everything I'm
going to do is is going to be a success
I think I still have paranoia that I'm
going to lose everything and I still
have massive fears about going broke um
that is something that my therapist and
I are working through still um but it
hasn't changed significantly I think
that someone had asked a question about
monthly expenses before I sold I think I
was spending anywhere between1 and
$15,000 a month my apartment at the time
was $4,000 a month I thought that was
astronomical I had a girlfriend my wife
now we live together so it was 2,000
each and I was like that is insane
$22,000 in rent I can that is just
like that's evil I thought um now when I
rent the place it's a bit more it I you
know 10 or 12 or 13,000 sometimes when I
go to um New York for the summer and so
I increased my rent price my home that I
live in in Austin I paid $900,000 for it
so my
monthly nut or my monthly mortgage and
taxes I think it's 5,000 or or 6,000
somewhere in between that with taxes and
so I think I increased my spend from
like 10 to 15 a month to like 20 to
25,000 a month maybe 20,000 a month when
I'm not in New York so I don't spend
what I think is a significant amount of
money I don't have any car payments I
have two cars a Tesla and a Mercedes
those are paid off I have a cleaning
lady who comes once a week that's $120 a
week um I do some health stuff so I have
a fancy gym and I go to fancy doctors
collectively that's a ,000 a month I
don't own any jewelry I I wear I'm
wearing a fresh clean tea it's a $10
t-shirt I wear those constantly um so I
don't buy a lot of fancy things so my
burn I think is relatively low um um
when I go out to eat I don't look at
prices and when I go to Whole Foods I
buy the fanciest stuff and that's
basically besides that I budget
everything else out and so
like I have a my wife is like insane
about this stuff she has a drawer full
of coupons so we went to Costco this
weekend because we had a $20 off or
something like that coupon so we still
use coupons or
coupons um but it has not changed
significantly I guess one significant
thing I hate flying I do not like to fly
at all so typically if I have to go
somewhere even if it's like 12 hours
away I tend to drive I do not like to
fly when I fly now I fly business class
um and so that makes a $300 flight $800
something like that but my increase
expenses rent went up
um um business class but I don't fly
often um and then my home doesn't have
fancy Furnishing my whole house cost
$30,000 to furnish so it hasn't really
changed significantly other than my
confidence my confidence has changed
significantly the idea of like creating
something from
nothing that changed
significantly how was that did that
answer those two questions love loved
every minute of it so now you can get
out of the hot seat on your personal
life and I'm going to throw to you the
this was the most liked question so what
were were your alternative business
ideas if you didn't do
Hampton so I um I'm I think I mentioned
this last podcast there's this thing
called eeky guy that I'm totally bought
into I'm very fascinated with Japanese
culture Japan has this like this
philosophy where I think I said it last
time it was like a vend diagram of like
what the world wants what the world
wants to pay for what you're good at
what you love doing I try to find
something in the middle one thing that
I'm obsessed about is data and numbers I
really am um like I
if you search if you go to my personal
blog which don't judge I started when I
was 21 and I quit blogging there but I
used to have this document called the
CEO
document and I tracked hundreds and
hundreds of people I read lots of
biographies and I tracked when they're
born when they started their
apprenticeship when they found success
and then like what the success was and I
made these like in-depth databases I'm
obsessed with databases I'm obsessed
with researching things so I have
hundreds of PAG pages of my notion
document where I deconstruct how
different companies work so I thought
about creating a research company or
database company the the the reason I
didn't start it was because I couldn't
find an appropriate problem to solve for
so I have all these databases of
information and I like to analyze them
and figure out what they mean but I
couldn't find a good use case or I
couldn't find a reason why people would
pay money for it other than it's
interesting
but I sought out like for six months
like different companies in the space
and I couldn't figure out the right like
go to market strategy so I wanted to
start a database company or research
company because I love it I thought
about starting a media company I do have
a non-compete so I can't start like a
business news email for another one year
I think um and so I couldn't do that and
so I kind of fell into Hampton because I
thought it was a it was perfect in my
little eeky guy it was like what I'm
good at what the world wants but I was
really obsessed with research businesses
we just had Jason yanowitz in the Pod
this episode will go live but he came uh
the episode before this and I asked him
a lot about research businesses I think
they could be really big I also think
that there's not a lot of like youngish
entrepreneurs attacking that space
because it's a pretty stodgy old space
that hasn't had a significant amount of
innovation and I'm but I'm very
fascinated by it so research in
databased businesses is what I wanted to
do one of my favorite examples is CB
insights I love CB insights I love
pitchbook I love those companies and I
wanted to build something like that all
right I got to tell you about one thing
that's one of the great joys of my life
you I'm not a cars guy and I'm not a
watch guy but there's one thing that
gives me a lot of joy and that is having
a virtual assistant uh you know here's
the scenario I'm running my companies
and even though I'm supposed to be this
uh CEO we all know I spend 20 30% of my
time just doing random stuff
that is not high value but it's just
tedious it's stuff that has to get done
but it's not creativity it doesn't
require me and it doesn't add a bunch of
value to the business it's just stuff
just stuff that has to get done and so
that stuff is what a virtual assistant
does like just this week alone you know
I lose my wallet so she goes to the DMV
website fills out a bunch of forms gets
me a new license or um you know every
morning people have their morning coffee
I have my morning metrics and my morning
metrics are basically all the business
metrics that I care about compiled she
goes she finds them from all the
different sources puts it in Excel sheet
takes a screenshot texts it to me so
that when I wake up in the morning I
don't go on Twitter or check my email
I'm looking at what what are the metrics
at and what do I need to do I'm focused
on the right things so having a virtual
assistant is a no-brainer whether it's
travel booking email inbox or just
knocking stuff off your personal to-do
list that would have just lingered there
forever um I think it's a no-brainer if
you're a business owner you should
definitely do it um I I think one of the
best places to find assistant is Shepard
so go to support shepard.com you know I
pay my assistant I think $8 an hour
something like that that's double what
she was making in her previous job so
it's a win for her and for me it's super
affordable it's something that um you
know you don't need to have the biggest
business ever be the biggest big shot in
order to afford it so it's amazing I now
do this for my co and my CMO too like I
just give them assistance without them
even asking because I know it makes them
more productive that's it does that for
me so of course it's going to do that
for them too so go to support.com check
them out um get an assistant and tell
them I sent you they'll take good care
of you if you do that so sport.com check
it
out our software is the worst have you
heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best hub spot grow better okay this
next question I love although it's
painful for me even to ask it because
it's really it it cuts deep uh this
comes from Omar what was the most
painful thing someone told you and how
did it change
you okay I saw that question and I was
trying to think of a good answer answer
my answer is
boring so my best friend his name's
Neville madora I met him because he had
a great blog on copywriting and one year
in 2013 I think it was 14 I cold emailed
them and I said Neville my name is Sam
I'm going to host this conference and I
want you to come speak and I'm going to
pay for your flight and I'm going to
take care of your accommodation well the
conference was really like 15 of my
friends hanging out talking and I bought
him a $250 Southwest flight and he slept
on my couch
and we became best friends after that
and when he was there at my in my
couch I gave him a towel to like take a
shower and it was like a moldy towel and
he was like dude you are disgusting
you're acting like this bachelor 23y old
which you are but like you need to be a
man you need to get your act together
this is disgusting and I remember that
changed my life when he and so I like
got together some of my
like my uh my domestic skill set I also
so like I was like I need to act like a
man I need to dress better I need to
like be more appropriate like I get I
got to get my act together so that
helped me a ton he also Neville does
this a lot he criticizes me all the time
but in a really nice way where he's like
I'm going to tell you this because I
love you but I'm going to give you
feedback and another thing was when I
met this woman that he was like dating
or maybe one of his friends I think it
was one of his friends he was like
you're asking way too many intense
questions the first time you meet
someone you need to chill and quit
talking about work and that was like
painful to hear because that was my
identity and so that changed how I uh
had conversations and so he's done a
good job Neville's eight uh six years
older than me so he's kind of done a
good job of like being my brother a
little bit and like teaching me how to
like act like a man so that was like a
good thing I remember when I started my
first company the
hustle and this CEO of a large
multi-billion dollar media startup that
everyone knows I'm not going to call him
out he told me I go I'm going to start
this thing called The Hustle I think it
could become a huge thing he said this
will never make more than a million
dollars a year just come and join my
company and I was so hurt because I
admired this guy so much and my
admiration for him turned to hatred not
really hatred but like rage I was like I
wna like I want to destroy you now and
the reason I thought that was because I
was so hurt my feelings were so hurt
that this guy that I admire just totally
on me and he was wrong but I
believed him for like 6 months I like
doubted everything I was like this is
stupid but he told me that he won't even
remember saying this this guy by the way
he probably made he thought it was like
an off-handed comment or that something
like that but it hurt my feelings so
badly that I remember that uh like
terribly and then the last thing was
like anytime a girlfriend has ever like
broken up with me that like that has
always like stung me I I I I'll remember
that for for decades like I'm still like
trying to like prove them wrong so like
I'm pretty sensitive uh to like
rejection yeah for sure the most painful
moments always come from high school I
think everyone can agree with that yeah
like high school and college girlfriends
where you're still trying to figure out
yourself a little bit and they like and
you get and and they're right like
you're not doing things the right way
but and they're rejecting you it's like
H it's the most painful thing ever girls
are so brutal okay this next question is
from Caitlyn what is one trendy business
model uh you think is
overhyped um I think the nft and web 3
stuff is just complete nonsense I think
it's inferior entrepreneurs slapping
their web 3 name on crap that no one
wants and hoping that it's going to work
so but everyone knows that now um I
think um what's overhyped I think
starting a newsletter is really popular
right now most people don't realize it
is a treadmill it is very challenging to
create new content just like this
podcast it's hard this is a hard job I
like it because I think I'm good at it
or I'm decent but it is very challenging
any type of content business very very
very very hard to do for like two or
three years um and newsletter the the
newsletter space significantly different
than when I started it is way more
competitive way more challenging so I
think that is a bit overhyped although I
would still start one because I like it
I think that most of the people in the
space are not going to work and it's
pretty bad their content stinks because
it's just a rinse and repeat of what
already has existed so so I think that's
quite overhyped I would say getting
popular on the internet can be awesome
because you get an audience but um in
general I think that creating businesses
based off your or like getting popular
on Twitter and and Instagram and things
like that I think it's incredibly empty
feeling for most people and I think it's
complete nonsense and your time would be
spent building a company or focusing on
your family than getting popular on
social media I think it's empty I think
that it's like small boy stuff I just
and I find it incredibly uninteresting
and there's many days that I regret
trying to like become popular on the
internet okay are you up to do one more
we'll do one more okay this one comes
from Jared seed he is moving to San
Francisco he's curious about this idea
of proximity to power so he's moving to
SF with the clear intention of start a
company and Surround himself with high
Achievers his question is what did you
do when you arrived d uh or what did
Shan do when he arrived in SF to start
laying the foundation to meet
interesting people and business
Builders moving to a big city when you
are young and have no family I think is
absolutely awesome my time I lived in SF
for 8 years I got angry at the
government and I left because it was
dangerous otherwise I would still be
there in a heartbeat I have no problem
paying the high taxes in order to live
there I think it's a beautiful place I
would still even go back there today if
my wife wanted to maybe so 100% worth it
I loved it um what I did when I got
there was I went to meetup.com and I
went to Crazy amounts of meetups I also
did uh I started an event so I created
it's so funny CA cuz it's so sea is one
of my best friends sea has a business
that does like close to 100 million a
year in Revenue we've had him on the Pod
you guys maybe have heard of him um he
so I created this book club called the
anti- MBA and the idea was we're going
to read one book per month and we're
going to break it up into quarters so
week one we're going to read a quarter
and discuss it week two the the second
half or whatever and I would have an
expert come in on the book's topic and
we would just shoot the uh with
like 30 or 20 people on this book and I
um posted ads on Craigslist on
meetup.com and where else I think I
bought an ad in the newspaper for like
$200 like I just posted these ads and
sea was one of the people who replied
and after doing that for every week for
about a year I had an email list of like
2,000 people who were like following
this book club online because I would
write out my notes from the the meeting
and doing that book club changed my life
so I just hosted a book club and it was
awesome it was so good it was uh such a
fun way to meet interesting people and
so that's what I did in order to meet
interesting people is we just read cool
books and we brainstormed and talked
about them most people by the way didn't
even read the book they just wanted to
talk about it because I wrote notes
ahead of time on like I wrote a summary
on the book so that changed my life the
way that I met Shawn was I had this
event called hustle con and there was
this article in TechCrunch about monkey
Inferno which was this incubator that
Shawn ran and I saw a picture of the his
office and it was magnificent and I cold
email Sean and I said hey man um I'm
hosting this event can I host the pre-
dinner at your office we we'll take care
of all the food I'll even hire some
someone to clean it up but can I just
like host it at your sick office and in
exchange you can come to the dinner and
meet all these wonderful speakers and
attendees and he said yes and that's how
I met Shawn and so I think what I did
what I think more people should do is
you just reach out to tons of people and
I would say don't even reach out to like
Ballers or people who are like ahead of
you find other peers who seem like they
got the juice who got the the Charisma
or who have who seem like they're going
someplace like for me it was Ryan Hoover
Ryan Hoover started this thing called
Product hunt we were buddies before he
even started it and I've got lots of
friends that are now incredibly
successful um where we were just all
like losers who were ambitious but we
had nothing and we and I did a good job
of like cold emailing those types of
people and we hung out a lot and we just
I I became wonderful friends with them
and it was through my book club it was
through cold emailing Twitter wasn't
popular I didn't even have a Twitter
back then so I just cold emailed tons of
people and I would highly recommend
that's what you do is find peers who you
think are going to go places and you
guys all try to succeed together and you
try to be pretty selfless in the sense
of like um like when I hosted my events
they all volunteered to help me out when
they needed something I helped them and
so just like succeeding together I think
was a really big deal now the issue is
that takes like 10 years or 15 years but
it's worth it um and you're not doing it
just because someone's going to be
successful like I had friends who are
artists and like they financially
weren't successful but it was just
people who were like kicking their dent
in the universe and that was addicting
to be around that and we all kind of did
it together and that's what what I did I
had a book club the anti- MBA is what it
was called because I was so jealous of
the I I didn't go to a fancy school I
remember when I moved to San Francisco I
took a bus out or a train out to
Stanford because I was like I want to
see what this shit's about like what's
what's so special about this place and I
felt like in awe and I was like so
jealous that I didn't know what Stanford
even was when I was in high school so I
was like I need to create my own
Stanford cuz I'm jealous of all these
people that went here and so that was
kind of the idea it was the anti- MBA it
was for and I organized it so I would
suggest book clubs meetup.com I don't
know is meetup.com still a thing I bet
you it is right now when I was in San
Francisco I went there like six months
ago and there was and someone someone
like recognized me and they go Sam I
love the Pod we're hosting a AI Meetup
and a hackathon right now do you want to
come and my wife and I were like yeah
let's go and so we just you got a car
here we were like at the farmers market
and they're like yeah I was like all
right come on I'm going with you and so
we went to this guy's Meetup and it was
magical I met all these AI people who I
knew nothing about and it was magical to
be in those meetups at these places
where you have like uh a homogeneous
group of people working on something
that is not mainstream it felt really
magical so I I would say go to those
events right awesome book club another
thing that you and Oprah have in common
I love it
yes we have a lot in common me and Oprah
so there were a lot of other questions
we didn't get to but we'll do another
one
a little later let me know if you guys
like this stuff
[Music]
peace